bei uns hat die nachricht erreicht dass
auch beim geflügelschlachthof wiesenhof
corona im großen stil ausgebrochen sein
soll
die fabriken in der nähe von oldenburg
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
meinem kollegen markus hibbeler markus
sag uns kann man auch bei wiesenhof
bereits von einem massenausbruch
sprechen
das wort massen aufbruch ist vielleicht
jetzt noch ein bisschen zu früh gesagt
aber fakt ist hier hinter mir im
schlachthof jedes land dazu phw gruppe
gehört deren bekannteste marke wiederum
wiesenhof ist wurden 23 mitarbeiter
jetzt positiv auf corona getestet von 50
mitarbeitern und morgen soll es dann das
hat der pressesprecher des landkreises
oldenburg im gegenüber unserer redaktion
gesagt ein massentest geben wo alle über
1100 mitarbeiter noch mal auf das neue
corona virus getestet werden soll
beim bereits etwas über die erkrankten
sind es auch in diesem fall bulgarische
rumänische schlacht arbeiter wir
arbeiten halt mehreren nationalitäten in
den schlachthof
allerdings sind die genauen die genauen
herkunftsländer der mitarbeiter noch
nicht bekannt der falls ja wie gesagt
relativ neu unsere zeit nur bekannt dass
es sich insgesamt 23 personen handelt
weiß man nie ob auch diese arbeiter in
solchen massen unterkünften
untergebracht sind wie man das jetzt
eben von dem fall wenn jetzt kennt also
lauter
laut des unternehmens sollen wohl
sämtliche sicherheitsmaßnahmen
eingehalten worden seien
inwieweit das jetzt der fall müssen
jetzt weitere untersuchungen zeigen
fakt ist dass die mitarbeiter die
betroffenen mitarbeiter jetzt erstmal
unter quarantäne kommt und dass das
unternehmen auch die ganzen
kontaktperson ermitteln will mit denen
die mitarbeiter in dem unternehmen bzw
in dem schlachtfeld an ihrer kontakt
hatten
vielen dank markus hibbeler bleibt also
zu hoffen dass der fall wiesenhof nicht
ein neuer todesfall wird